[Music]
welcome and thank you all for coming
before we start the discussion this
evening I'd like to acknowledge the land
on which the CBC operates it has been a
site of human activity for fifteen
thousand years this land is the
territory of the human wind dot and
petram First Nations the Seneca and most
recently the Mississauga's of the Credit
River today the meeting place of Toronto
is still the home to many indigenous
people from across Turtle Island and we
are grateful to have the opportunity to
work in their community and on their
territory welcome everyone and thank you
for coming to the 2017 sea pharmacy talk
on science and society I'm Hugh Segal
and head of Massey college and Massey's
history for half a century of building
interdisciplinary insight and
intergenerational wisdom a part of its
core purpose and principle is part of
why we are so honored to partner with
CFR this evening
three years ago Massey College and the
Canadian Institute for Advanced Research
came together to inaugurate these talks
we recognized that scholarship and
science are powerful tools for
understanding and shaping our world and
that it has profound implications for
how we live and think these talks are
intended to explore the connections
between research and the broader
community and to help catalyze new ways
of thinking and deeper levels of
understanding each year we invite a
speaker to examine a subject that is
important to the world and that is
informed by the rich interplay of ideas
between science and culture anyone who
reads the news knows that breakthroughs
and artificial intelligence are coming
fast and furious these days artificial
intelligence promises to revolutionize
everything from transportation and
health
here to our relationships with machines
and the very idea of what it means to be
human and nothing that happens quickly
or is of that kind of importance is
without its ethical social and economic
implications first though it is my
distinct pleasure to introduce dr. Alan
Bernstein a senior fellow at Massey
president and CEO of CFR and this year's
laureate for the freezin prize for
outstanding medical research ladies and
gentlemen dr. Burton thank you very much
Hugh and and welcome everyone I'm truly
delighted to be here as presidents of
CFR the Canadian Institute for Advanced
Research I'm very much looking forward
to our speakers talk today from dr. joe
el pino from a gil university but first
like to recognize two CFR board members
who are in the audience today barb Sami
it's our our distinguished Board Chair
and Lawrence petland one of our newest
board members for those of you who are
not familiar with CFR we're a Canadian
based global research organization
that's sponsored by visionary
individuals corporations foundations in
the governments of Canada Quebec Ontario
Alberta and British Columbia as well as
partners in Canada the US France Germany
and China we bring together some of the
world's top researchers across
disciplines to tackle important
questions facing humanity for example
one of CFR's program's bio-inspired
solar energy is tackling the challenge
of climate change by learning how to
harness and store energy from the Sun
taking advantage what Mother Nature has
been doing for the last 400 million
years photosynthesis others are
examining what what goes into making a
society successful some of you may have
read about the the collision of two
neutron stars that was reported last
week that led to the release of
gravitational waves our fellows in the
program and gravity in the extreme
universe have played central roles in
the recent detection of those
gravitational waves from those black
holes and neutron stars one of CFR's
great successes and why we're here
tonight is artificial intelligence or AI
in 2002 a University of Toronto
researcher Jeff Hinton and Jeff I don't
know if you're in the audience here this
evening brought together a CFR program
now called learning in machines and
brains Jeff's idea was that we could
learn from the original thinking machine
our brains Jeff pioneered the AI
technique now called deep learning and
he is considered universally as the
godfather of AI last spring he was
recently named a distinguished fellow by
CFR's Board of Directors in recognition
of his outstanding science and his
long-standing contributions to C far
Jeff's worked with other CFR fellows
including young laocoön of New York
University and now head of AI at
Facebook and yoshua bengio of the
université de maría al who are co
directors of our program in learning and
machines and brains of help to make
Canada a true powerhouse in artificial
intelligence talent it's actually hard
to pick up a newspaper or turn on the
radio without hearing a story about AI
these days and for that we have Geoff
Hinton to blame our speaker tonight is
another example of Canadian research
excellence in artificial intelligence
dr. joe el pino is a CFR senior fellow
and a leader in the field of artificial
intelligence she's an associate
professor in William Dawson scholar at
McGill University where she co-directs
the reasoning and learning lab last
month she was also named head of the
Montreal Facebook artificial
intelligence Research Laboratory her
research focuses on developing new
models and algorithms for planning and
learning in complex partially observable
domains she works on applying these
algorithms to complex problems in
robotics in healthcare and in
conversational agents she serves on the
editorial boards of the Journal of
artificial intelligence research and the
Journal of machine intelligence research
and as president-elect of the
International machine learning society
last year she was named a member of the
college of new scholars artists and
scientists by the Royal Society of
Canada ladies and gentlemen please join
me in welcoming dr. joe el pino it's a
pleasure to be here we've all heard
about AI over the last year it's been a
very exciting year for people in the
research community part of what I'm here
to do today is to perhaps share some of
that excitement with you more broadly
and also to demystify some of the
aspects of what we actually do in this
area we're not that far away from the
day where cars are going to be driving
themselves it seems like it's maybe
going to be tomorrow I assure you we
have a few more years before we get
there but it's not progress that happens
overnight this is really the result of
several years of work in this area when
I was doing my PhD studies in the late
1990s I moved to Pittsburgh to attend
Carnegie Mellon University and there
already there were folks working on
developing self-driving cars we could
actually go down to a basement building
building did what's called in the days
and when you went there you saw some
great big vehicles one of them was
reputed to have driven from one coast
from the east coast to the west coast
autonomously
this was 1990s when you asked a few more
questions of the engineers but you were
told well you know it drove from one
coast to the other about 95 percent of
the time it seems pretty good right and
then you ask which 95 percent of the
time
oh the part where it was on the highway
the part where I didn't have to switch
lanes and it just followed the white
line on the right right so we had some
work to do between that time and now
there's been tremendous progress a lot
of that progress is in machine learning
a lot of that progress is in computer
vision and our ability to understand the
world the progress is not just in
autonomous driving we're seeing it also
in our interactions and our new ways of
communicating in our social interactions
it's not so unusual anymore these days
to speak to a bot some of you may have
had lovely conversations with Siri with
echo sometimes a little bit frustrating
they tend to have very short memory
these devices we don't know why because
there's a big hard drive in the machine
still the interaction is changing one
thing that's also changing is really our
interaction with all of the digital
world in many ways all of our
interaction through this digital world
are mediated by AI what information we
receive the context in which it's
presented the order in which we receive
the information is decided by AI
algorithms the information that we
project that is shared with the world is
also mediated by AI algorithms and so
that technology has already started to
impact our lives it's not always
invisible forms through cars through
assistants but it is there in many cases
when looking at a time of big change
it's interesting to sometimes look for
analogies in our past and perhaps one
relevant analogy in this case is the
great Industrial Revolution in that case
what we observed is a period of
transition where machines were suddenly
able to take on tasks mechanical
physical tasks where human had been
doing the work now machines were doing
the work and what we're seeing with the
AI revolution is that in this case it's
the cognitive parts of our contribution
our ability to think to understand
complex information which is being taken
on by the machine and suddenly we have
computer algorithms that can process
information that can plan that can
conceive of how to incorporate knowledge
and do so in a way that essentially
produces behavior we would associate
with human intelligence we're calling it
a revolution because the impact of this
new cognitive artificial cognitive
technology is really showing up in many
different sectors many different sectors
of our economies and of our societies
let me specify a little bit more clearly
what I mean by artificial intelligence
it's a collection of abilities
to essentially think and so that means
modules for planning modules for
understanding the natural language
understanding images of course trying to
figure out how to learn from that
information also the ability to actually
model the world to make predictions
about the world to search through vast
amount of information in contrast to
human intelligence our machine version
right now works in silos so we have
algorithms that can do planning
algorithms that can understand images
and different algorithms that can
understand images we're still really
struggling with developing machines that
can cross the boundaries between these
tasks and so where we can build an
algorithm that we'll be able to
translate text from English into French
and we can build a different algorithm
they'll be able to play poker we can
probably build another algorithm that
can distinguish between a recording of
Glenn Gould and a recording of Gordon
Downey it's difficult to build one
machine that can do all of these things
in an integrated way in many ways this
is one of the challenge that lay ahead
when we want to build better artificial
intelligence is to figure out what is
the neural glue that we will need to
make all of these abilities work in a
very seamless way something that nature
has achieved beautifully we're still
struggling to get into our machines the
field of AI as the science goes back to
the 1950s and there's been a radical
shift in many ways in how AI is
implemented in the machines over the
last few years in the early 1950s we had
luminaries individuals like Alan Turing
Claude Shannon who are developing early
versions of computers and while they
were building our very computers they
were already thinking of how to use
these machines to behave in an
intelligent way Alan Turing was one of
the first to imagine computers that
could have a conversation carry out a
conversation with a human Claude Shannon
was busy building computer programs to
play chess this late 1950s early 1960s
their approach to AI and the approach
that persisted all the way through the
80s and early 90s
was really an approach that was based on
a programmatic philosophy of AI in that
case we would be writing bodies of
instructions precise instructions in a
machine understandable language to tell
the Machine how to synthesize
information and how to make good
decisions and what has changed in more
recent years is really an approach that
we could call Show and Tell approach to
training machines essentially showing
examples of how we make decisions and
letting the Machine draw its conclusions
about how to perform certain tasks so if
we think of a task of analyzing for
example images brain images to do Eggman
tation of tumors in these images it's
difficult to write out a very precise
set of instructions for how to detect a
tumor in an image one would probably
have to give different instructions for
all different brains for different
patients different images even humans
are trained not in a programmatic way
but really with a show and tell by
examples by looking at many examples and
so the current AI paradigm the one that
is really kind of sweeping us off in
this revolution is one that is based on
learning on showing machine examples of
how it's done and distilling that
knowledge a few breakthroughs that are
really worth mentioning
computer vision we have really changed
our ability to understand images and one
of the reasons we are now much closer to
having cars that drive not only on
highways but also in cities is because
of these breakthroughs our ability to
understand pedestrians vehicles bicycles
traffic signs traffic lights and so on
once you can understand that complex
information you can actually have much
more robust behavior in the world and so
in terms of image computer vision the
breakthrough is in some ways achieved by
the availability of data a group of
people got together produced a beautiful
benchmark data set called image net that
data set contained a million images much
bigger than any other data set available
before not only were there at million
images these images had been annotated
so someone had gone and indicated in the
image a little box around each of the
key objects and had put a word to say
this
is a dog and this is a bird and this is
a car and through this data set we could
train our machines to pick out a
thousand and more different types of
objects in 2012 we started seeing
algorithms based on machine learning
that we're starting to exceed previous
approach based on more classical
analysis of images around 2015 our
algorithms were actually exceeding human
level performance
so the algorithm predict more accurately
what objects were in an image a lot of
that power came actually from the fact
that the computer could distinguish
between about 125 different categories
of dogs and many dozens different
categories of flowers which most humans
probably don't care to learn when we
look under the hood of these machines
what is happening in terms of the
technology their algorithms computer
program telling us how to learn in many
ways the algorithms that were behind
these breakthrough is that many elements
that had been known for 15 20 years what
really changed our ability to solve the
problem was the availability of the very
large data set and the availability of
computing platforms GPU platforms to
compute the algorithms speech
recognition similar process where we saw
quick improvement in particular around
2010 2012 and so on our ability to
understand natural language from audio
to written speech improved drastically
these are two different domains
understanding images understanding
speech and yet in some ways this deep
learning technology is the engine that
drives these progresses it's been
applied to many other types of data also
and here in Canada we've been really
lucky to be at the forefront of this
revolution we've been sitting in the
front seats watching it happen because
we've had some of the leading
researchers Alan mentioned them in his
introduction geoff hinton Jana Kuhn
Jakob NGO and of course the great
population of grad students that they've
trained over the years all of them have
been training many many grad students
who have now moved on to join University
and Industry labs around the world
carrying out this work let's
a little bit deeper under the hood and
tried to understand what's going on in
this case one analogy that is quite
interesting to look at is the parallel
between biological neurons and what
we're calling artificial neurons because
this deep learning is really a way to
adapt some of these intuition so in a
biological neuron you can think of a
biological neurons and my biology
friends in the room and give me if I
could do this in a very crude way
essentially you can think of it as a
unit of computation it's a unit in the
brain which receives information there's
some dendrites at one end of the neuron
that receive messages from other neurons
there's some operation that gets
computed inside the neuron the
neurochemical level and then the neuron
decides whether to send out a message or
not and if it decides to send out an s
message are essentially an electrical
message passed along the axon that gets
sent around to many other neurons and so
this notion that information gets in
something gets decided and in some cases
information goes out is very similar to
what's going on in our artificial
neurons in that case the neuron is
actually a line of code or a unit in
memory in the computer that receives
information from other pieces of the
memory in the computer or information
from sensors in the case of a robot
information is computed at the level of
the neuron and gets passed on to other
neurons and things get really
interesting when we combine many of
these neurons together we're not very
good at building very complex intricate
ways to combine this we usually layer
out our neurons in a set of different
layers it's quite useful just from a
mathematical point of view and that we
have to in the end of the day represent
this in the memory of a computer so we
have vectors and arrays and information
gets plugged into there the connections
between the neurons essentially are the
process through which we acquire
learning and so by strengthening
connections between certain neurons we
can actually strengthen certain
predictions so when we talk about
training a machine learning algorithm
what we really mean is figuring out what
is the right set of weights on these
connections how strong or how
to make these connections in a way that
once the message get passed through all
of the layers of neurons we have a
prediction at the end that matches what
the label should be so if you think of
trying to do image classification in
this case I would take an image on the
input side each of the pixels in the
image would be associated with a
separate neurons and through each of the
layer of the neural network we're
computing more and more abstract version
of the information from lines and color
patches to patterns to the end
predicting whether it's a dog or a cat
that's in the neural network things get
particularly interesting when you start
to stack many many layers of these
neurons together dozens of layers of
these neurons this is one of the network
the Google net that was doing very well
a few years ago in terms of the image
net challenge it has on the order of six
hundred thousand neurons there's about
six million parameters to train over
here so you can imagine the amount of
data you need to see to get good weight
configurations on these six million
parameters the progress we're doing is
not limited to just images or just
speech there's really interesting work
being done at the intersection of vision
and language this is a case that deals
with a problem of image captioning so in
this case the neural network receives an
image we present an image and the goal
of the machine is to produce not just
one word right not just pizza but a
whole sentence right two pizzas sitting
on top of a stove top oven right
generating that sentence all of the
words in a way that is consistent with
what's shown in the image but also
consistent with the rules of grammar in
this case in the English language though
we can do that in several other
languages also the second image the
label that was generated a group of
young people playing a game of Frisbee
quite remarkable something that a few
years ago we really couldn't think of
doing the machines are not perfect right
we have a great set of bloopers on the
left here obviously a refrigerator
filled with lots of food and drinks
right that your fridge looks like I
don't think so
on the other side a yellow
school bus parked in a parking lot not
quite it's quite likely that in our data
set most of the images that featured
transportation and something big and
yellow were a yellow school bus probably
not a lot of images of cars like that in
our training data set and so you start
to see that in many cases our algorithms
are making mistakes when they haven't
been exposed to the right kind of data
one technique that we have been looking
at to improve in cases where machines
are not doing as well as we want is by
letting the machine on its own improve
its ability and so there's a branch of
machine learning called reinforcement
learning that pursues the development of
algorithms for that case in the case of
reinforcement learning the strategy is a
little bit different right deep learning
typically is a supervised learning
approach I will show you an image I will
tell you there's a dog in that image in
reinforcement learning the machine gets
to apply a little bit more trial and
error it's not that different from how
animals pets learn or how children may
learn right they try different behaviors
and sometimes these behaviors result in
a good reward the animal may find food
the children may receive positive
reinforcement from their parents the
agent learns through trial and error to
exhibit behaviors that are consistent
with getting a lot of reward and so
we're essentially building algorithms to
train our machines in that way the
advantage of this is that we don't then
need to be very systematic about
providing the teaching examples the
machine can try out different behaviors
and learn which behaviors learn to
finding the cheese and the maze in which
behavior learned leads to just finding
yourself in a corner perhaps the
greatest success of reinforcement
learning with over the last few years is
the alphago system produced by deep mine
it was able to essentially learn how to
play the game of go there was
spectacular success many people in the
AI community thought we were still a
decade away from being able to crack
this game very difficult game for many
reasons and yet 2016 we had a system
built with the combination of deep
learning in the deep learning piece of
the system they lever
several games from experts millions of
games from expert go player and they
essentially got the machine to imitate
whether the go player was doing so
that's a supervised learning approach
and then when it got to a certain level
of performance they told the Machine to
go ahead and play against itself and
that's what allowed the machine to get
to the next level of performance beat
the human champion at this very
difficult game the results were
published in a nature paper and were
really quite interesting from the
community perhaps what's interesting to
notice if you look closely at who were
the authors on this nature paper at
least five of them were actually trained
in Canada in Montreal in Toronto and in
mminton they did their graduate studies
here and are now working at deep mind
working on this project last week
another phenomenal result from the same
team in this case the ability to master
the game of go without any human
knowledge so in this case they forego
looking at any previous games by expert
and the machine through self play
starting from scratch complete inability
to play all the way to a level beyond
any human player completely trained by
self play so really interesting result
I'm still coming out for those of you
who may be motivated for higher impact
applications than the game of go there
is so much potential for using both
supervised learning and reinforcement
learning in particular in the field of
health care and I will finish by
spending just a few minutes talking
about one of the project that's been
carried out at McGill in part by
students in my own lab we've been
looking for several years at how to
improve our ability to treat individuals
with epilepsy epilepsy is one of the
most prevalent neurological diseases in
many cases patients can be treated by
pharmacological drug treatment in some
cases surgery is also a good solution
but for some patients in particular when
the seizures are spread out across
several sections of the brain it's hard
to go in there and do resection surgery
without impacting cognitive abilities
and so we've been looking at therapies
in particular neural stimulation therapy
where a device applies electrical
stimulation in the brain in real time in
an attempt to disrupt the incidence of
seizures the technology has been
developed over a few years but there's
really interesting
question in terms of how do we optimize
the parameter of the stimulation such
that we can improve our ability to
disrupt seizures this is an example of a
seizure as seen in the EEG signal so in
this case the information we get from
the world is in the form of this EEG
sampled at high frequency from the
brain's often we have several sensors in
parallel electrodes recording this in
this case there's a very nice deflection
in the middle which is this seizure that
we're considering so what we want is
essentially to be able to disrupt this
seizure sufficiently and the idea of
neuro stimulation the theory behind
neuro stimulation is that epilepsy
occurs when several of the neurons in
the brain are essentially recruited to
all fire in a synchronous manner so they
all start firing at the same time which
causes this big disruption and after a
while the neuro chemicals are depleted
and they can't fire anymore and then
there's a period post seizure that
happens and so by applying neuro
stimulation every time
electrical stimulation is applied that
forces some of the neurons nearby to
fire which then forces some of the other
neurons to fire so you're essentially
disrupting the ability for the brain to
hyper synchronize and therefore seizures
can't happen and so what we're really
interested in doing is figuring out how
can we optimize the parameter of that
neuro stimulation strategy and do it in
a way that we can improve the outcomes
for individuals epilepsy is a highly
variable disease this types of seizures
how they occur how they manifest change
just a lot from one person to another so
there's not really a sense that one set
of parameters in the device is going to
be helpful for many individuals there's
really an opportunity there to learn
through trial and error what might be
the right strategy the might
configuration of parameters to maximally
benefit a particular individual and so
we started a project a few years ago in
collaboration with researchers at the
Montreal Neurological Institute to
design a better AI driven control
algorithm for neuro stimulation devices
where the input was this multi-channel
EEG signal and the output was actually a
schedule on the stimulation something
that would tell the stim
leading electrode when to send a signal
and when to hold back the idea was that
we would attempt to minimize the
incident of seizures but also to
simultaneously minimize the amount of
stimulation that we deliver such that we
can actually preserve healthy tissue
preserve battery on the device and so we
used reinforcement learning to optimize
this strategy and we were able to show
that we come up with a policy that's
highly diverse what you're seeing the
little bars down there right that's the
policy that was discovered by the AI
agent what you'll see is that in some
phases there's increased amount of
stimulation that happens just at the
moment where there it seems like there
might be seizure onset there's a greater
incidence of these spikes which we call
these interictal events and later on in
the process
this policy spaces out so we can
actually space out much more the
incidence of stimulation because we know
that the brain is not in an immediate
risk of seizing at that point these are
experiments we conducted with animal
models of epilepsy we haven't yet moved
on to human experiments as you can
imagine having an AI system disrupt our
neural system is something that is not
without risk and so we have to be very
careful in our experimentation but
animal models provide a really great way
to be able to acquire data and test out
some of these ideas this is but one
example of really a broader movement
towards looking at AI strategies for
optimizing treatment and in particular
optimizing personal treatment I'm
particularly interested in seeing how
well we can do for all of these diseases
where you need a sequence of
interventions there's some disease where
it's easier to think of a single
intervention but there's many cases I've
listed a few there where we have
collaborations between AI researchers
and medical researchers to try to
improve the outcomes by optimizing the
discovery as well as the personalization
of the treatment strategy let me close
with a few final remarks first of all
there's a few ingredients in my mind to
have a successful AI revolution one of
them that we talk a lot about is the
incidence of data right lots of data
lots of data is often fabulous we don't
always have
the privilege of lots of data the work
that we did with epilepsy in particular
we had data from about a dozen animals
it's not a lot of data it may look like
a lot the file may be big on the
computer because we're recording from
multiple channels but having just a
dozen animals with epilepsy I assure you
is a very small sample and so we have to
learn as efficiently as we can from the
data that is available in some cases we
need very high-performance computing
infrastructure to help us process
through the data when we're looking at
robotics autonomous driving we have data
coming in from multiple cameras we have
data coming from these three dimensional
point clouds generates a ton of data so
we have to be able to process through
that quickly in real time of course we
need a team of talented computer
scientists data scientists machine
learning experts one of the big
challenges for your our universities in
the next few years is to train and
produce the talent at the speed that
everyone is hoping we will and to be
able to help our industry our public
institutions have people who have these
kinds of qualification helped them in
this transition time in many cases we
also need to have good domain-specific
knowledge so when I look at applying
machine learning techniques to improve
the treatment of healthcare I can't go
in there on my own with my machine
learning toolkit and hope to crack a
problem such as how do we improve the
treatment for epilepsy there has to be a
close collaboration with people who
understand the disease the dynamics
people who work with the patients people
who know how the healthcare system works
and we can think of how we will deploy
the strategies in a way that's effective
in the ecosystem and finally of course
we need to have more efficient learning
algorithms architectures a lot of the
research we do in our labs is really on
this fifth point below but all of the
ingredients have to be aligned I think
for us to be able to make progress
there's been a lot of noise about IT
companies competing for AI talent this
is just but a very small sample of
companies where we have seen a lot of AI
activities in the recent years in many
cases right they're opening the
field but as we progress really what we
need is to figure out how we can have AI
talent but also AI readiness across many
many different sectors of our economy
and our societies and so this is one of
the challenge that I think is ahead for
us in Canada fortunately I think one of
the reasons we have been able to lead
the way in this is really because we
have a pan-canadian strategy on this
there's talent from coast to coast the
bigger centers are in Toronto Montreal
Edmonton but there's several excellent
researchers and training programs in
many other cities in Vancouver in
Waterloo in Quebec City and cross the
board and so that next generation of
students is soon going to be coming out
of our universities and we hope are
going to help us in the future doing
this and let me close with just saying
that I look forward to the discussion
with Massie fellows thank you I'm now
going vite three junior fellows with
Massey graduate students to join me here
on the stage so that they can put some
questions to our guest of honor sitting
next to yo L is Johanna Pokorny a PhD
candidate in her fifth year at the
Department of Anthropology University of
Toronto and a junior fellow at Massey
College in her dissertation project
which is situated at the intersection of
anthropology and science studies Johanna
ethnographically studies laboratory life
of a group of neuroscientists who take
up recent ideas of neuroplasticity
resting-state research
neural imaging and computational
neuroscience techniques to studying the
living and dynamic brain Shane Sanderson
he is a first year non-resident junior
fellow at Massey College and is
currently pursuing a PhD in robotics at
the University of Toronto he holds an
MBA in technology and innovation from
the Ted Rogers School of Management at
Ryerson University and a Bachelor in
English from
University in Montreal and sitting
between those two junior fellows is
Sasha millage first-year resident junior
fellow doctoral student in the computer
science department her primary research
area is computational linguistics the
study of natural human language from the
viewpoint of computer science in
particular she's interested in what
computational models of human language
say about the human mind I will leave
the stage now because junior fellows at
Massey College do not need any
moderation in fact they resist it as a
matter of principle which i think is a
good thing over to you colleagues
well I'll begin I thank you so much
Joelle for a wonderful talk um I want to
get right into the discussion by
focusing on some of the socio-economic
impacts of AI so specifically the rapid
economic disruption it will introduce
such as job displacement and perhaps the
attendant increasing wealth disparities
that may come with this so being
familiar with the innovation in AI
development what sorts of policy and/or
preparation would you recommend we take
to deal with these socio-economic
impacts I'm not a policy expert right i
write computer algorithms and it's hard
to write a computer algorithm to produce
good policy I can assure you one thing I
can say is you know there's a lot of
prediction now about trying to just
figure out in particular which sectors
of our industry are most likely to
change and trying to figure out in what
way to prepare in a sense the next
generation for that change some of the
changes that we worry about on the onset
right self-driving car being one of them
there's a huge number of people who make
a living driving trucks cars and so on
and it's interesting to talk to people
on the industry side in particular for
the trucking industry one thing we're
hearing from from leaders and that is
that it's very difficult for them to
recruit new people to that particular
job it turns out that driving large
trucks coast-to-coast long hours is not
a really attractive job for many people
so even industry leaders are looking
forward to having more automation to
relieve some of the pressure it's not
the same in all sectors when we talk to
people in radiology and we evoke the
possibility that radiologists will
perhaps not be so useful in that case
it's a little bit of a shock because
it's people who have many many years of
studies and so it's a little bit
difficult to to help them prepare order
for them to accept that but reality I I
would say just looking at the spectrum
of occupations right one thing that
stands out is cases where jobs where the
type of information that has to be
processed is relatively uniform right
one reason it's easier to think that we
may have machines replacing radiologists
then emergency room physician is because
in one case it's very uniform
information so it's easier to train a
machine for whenever someone has to
process very complex information and
also perform a really wide variety of
actions it's a lot harder to think of
machines taking on these roles but
that's a little bit far away from policy
and I realize but at least rule of thumb
of seeing where we're gonna see the most
disruption going back to the the the may
be a little bit closer to your question
right this how do we prepare for this in
a way I think human society is
incredibly adaptable I had a colleague
who gave a presentation on this recently
encoded the following statistics he said
at the beginning of the 20th century
there was about 40 percent of Americans
who were engaged in agriculture and at
the end of the century it was about four
percent of Americans who were working in
agriculture and yet unemployment rate
was lower and also during that century
we saw the massive movement of women
into the workforce and so I think that
the jobs that will be available for our
children are going to be completely
different than the jobs that were
available when I went to university and
perhaps when you went to university but
but I think
there will be very interesting problems
to solves and things to do do you have
any recommendations to us as young
scholars I know you mentioned you
prepare your daughter a little bit so or
do you have any recommendations for
young people as to how they should
prepare I tried not to intervene too
much a long-term plan and give her space
you know but yes I think yeah you know I
crying a really large diversity of
skills is always useful right something
to think about mathematics and science
are definitely going to be very useful
in many ways I think in particular we
have a big challenge in terms of how to
incorporate more computing into our
curriculum at the lower level I know a
lot of the people looking at the
curriculum for the k-12 are really
looking at how can we introduce children
to computing programming earlier and how
to do it in an age-appropriate way and
so I expect this is going to there's
gonna be a lot of movement in that
respect over the next few years you
mentioned at the end you know how are we
incorporating more technical
perspectives and coding into different
curriculums you also mentioned at the
start yeah you know in your humility of
well I'm not necessarily one to comment
on policy to what degree do we need to
be worrying about technical
practitioners coders engineers not
necessarily having a broad enough
perspective on what they're doing and
some of the ethical implications of AI
mmm-hmm it's very interesting right now
because the technology gets better it
becomes much more important to have
these conversations across different
fields and boundaries and I think the
the issue that you point out is is
definitely there right as much as we
have people on the one side who are
building policies looking at the
ethnical implications who may not have
had the opportunity to have the more
technical computing training on the
other side we also have people who have
been trained in a very narrow scientific
way and may not have as much broader
culture in terms of the sociological
impacts policy impacts economics and so
on
and so we we have a gap
which usually means that when we have
these conversation it takes us a while
to find a common language I'm really
hopeful that the next generation will
not have as much of a gap that we will
have an ability to you know go back to
Renaissance type of training where
people were really exposed to a much
broader spectrum of ideas make more
polymaths I have a question that kind of
goes in a different direction it seems
like current AI algorithms are largely
inspired by the human brain and I'm
wondering do you see this inspiring or
guiding research ai research for the
foreseeable future
and I suppose another way of saying this
is is the human brain the gold standard
for AI research or could it possibly go
in a different direction yeah I think
you'll get different answers depending
who you ask and since I hope this stage
today I'll give you my version but you
know take it with a grain of salt the
human brain is a beautiful machine but
it's also one that we understand very
very poorly right in some sense people
worry about not understanding what's
going on when a machine makes a decision
but I can tell you I can trace that
decision in a machine much better than I
can trace it in a human right now and so
the human brain is great inspiration but
we don't understand everything that's
going on in there the other aspect is
that human brain and the Machine have
different materials different biology
right and so there's some constraints
physical constraints that are associated
with those differences and so some
things that the brain can do we cannot
do in the machines because these
physical constraints are different and I
should also say right we talked about
reinforcement learning which has nice
parallel with psychology we talked about
neural networks which have nice
parallels with neurons but there's a
whole lot of other things going on under
the hood in terms of training a neural
network there's a ton of optimization
that's built in these techniques from
optimization come to us not from a
biology inspiration they really come
from a really fundamental understanding
of
Maddox and how to optimize functions and
so there's a merging of these ideas and
you know I think the human brain analogy
speaks to people and it's easy to both
for the scientists to draw inspiration
and for us to communicate across
boundaries of field but it's only a
piece of the story of how we really
build these algorithms my turn
I guess the engineer / businessman and
me wants to get a little bit applied so
I'll ask you a double prong question
what's been the most interesting or your
favorite application you've seen of AI
so far and what are you most excited for
that's on the horizon the most exciting
that I'd see I can tell you the most of
the things that I've been most excited
to work on really is this epilepsy
project that I talked about that's why I
chose I mean we've done many projects
over the years but this is one that I've
been most excited about just because
it's been so hard to do there's really a
beautiful problem right there's people
who live with epilepsy which I could go
on for a long time but it's a disease
that really impacts people's life their
ability to carry out normal activities
and yet we have this really interesting
new technology solution we don't have a
lot of data to solve the problem we have
these animal models that are really
different from the humans but they're
kind of the best we have to get the data
and sew it but this kind of problem
there are so many of them across the way
and one thing that's wonderful about
working in AI right now is that
essentially the doors of all these other
fields are open to you I never said I
haven't even studied biology in high
school this is embarrassing two minutes
on such a big stage but right I didn't
take high school biology and yet because
I know something about data science
about mathematics and algorithms I get
to work with some of the world's best
neuroscientists trying to solve these
problems and we kind of come at it from
our different limited point of views and
so that type of interdisciplinary
project is so exciting there's so many
cool ones to do okay so you've mentioned
data a lot right there there were
challenges in there
but data and algorithms have come up
multiple times
what can al Gurren data not do what can
they not do today that you think they
might do in the near future and is there
something maybe they might never be able
to do I would say you know there's
usually some you have to ask the right
question of your data so it's a question
you know it's a little bit of a dance
between the data and the algorithm and
if you tick the data and you pair it
with the wrong algorithm then you're not
gonna get a very interesting answer so
one of our challenges as we do the more
applied side of this work is really just
look at the data become familiar with
the data try to understand you know how
what does it smell like what is its
color what does it sound like really
tried to get the characteristics of that
data and then to pair up the best
algorithms that we have and in some case
we don't have the right fit right it's
just not the right shoe for that foot
and we have to go and make a new shoe
but really a lot of what we do is trying
to do that and so if we find cases where
we don't have a good set of algorithms
to match with new data then this is
often when we get more creative and
we're going to go and create new
algorithms to fit that data so it's an
exciting place how often do you have to
invent a new algorithm aren't usually
just picking things out of your toolbox
or do you have to get creative like
every week I'm not saying I invent a
great algorithms every week but yeah
every week I have I have a fantastic
group of grad students about 15 grad
students or so at McGill we are so
creative
in it and it's often the case that you
know we picked problems that are hard
enough that we don't have the right
algorithms to solve them and that's when
things get interesting sometimes when we
start a new project we don't know yet
right I'll have a first conversation and
someone I had a colleague at McGill came
we had a meeting of year two ago he had
wonderful data
tracking
primates in Zimbabwe and he had like the
tracking data from them over several
years and he was like what can I predict
with this data and honestly we didn't
know we started playing with the data we
tried to build predictive models so if
you see where the primate has been over
several days can you predict where
they're going to go next and it turns
out the best algorithms we had we're not
doing a very good job and so then we
build a new set of algorithms for doing
that that our new model for a time
series prediction we applied it for
these particular primates but now the
algorithms out we published it and then
people can use it for whatever other
types of data that they might have so I
would say every week we work on trying
to create a new algorithm some of them
don't pan out many of them don't pan out
once in a while we hit on a good idea
Joell what do you think is the largest
misconception the general public has
about AI hmm or the current state of AI
one of the misconceptions I think is the
fact that AI is this black box that's
making decisions right information goes
in does something to the information and
out pops a decision and this notion that
we can never understand what's going on
in the black box right in and this goes
back I think to a comment I made earlier
I think in many ways we know what's
going on in the black box right I have a
neural network it may have 600,000
neurons if I present the same image I
can trace very precisely where it
predicted that this was actually an
image of a fish I can trace it
the difficulty is it's not a simple
story and so once I've traced it all I
can't necessarily go and explain to you
in 20 words or less why it decided that
it was a fish humans are much better at
doing that humans are much better at
saying well here is the context and I
made this decision and here's why I made
this decision right humans are good at
coming up with that short answer now
what's interesting is that in many cases
it's not clear that the human answer the
reason humans are giving is actually
reason they made that decision and so we
can't go back in their brain and trace
why what was the sequence of neurons
that fired very precisely to go from
seeing that information right you're
driving along you see something and you
decide to veer to the right or hit the
brakes the human may bring a narration
to explain it but we don't have a clue
what's going on and so people have this
notion that Oh humans are so
understandable and explainable and
machines are these black boxes where we
know nothing about what happens I think
it's like humans are really good at
building a narration and machines are
not so good at building a narration yet
so what happens when we make the
machines that can build the narration as
well is that a good thing I think that's
a good thing if anything it's a good
thing because it establishes a richer
dialogue between the Machine and the
human and the reason we need this richer
dialogue is because as we move forward
right we talked about some of the fact
that machines are going to become more
prevalent in the workforce as we move
along humans and machines are gonna work
together it's not going to be a case of
sunlight right all the machines move
into the workforce we close the doors
and the humans go off and we play golf
for the next several years right for a
long time there's going to be a
partnership the machines are gonna make
predictions the humans are gonna look at
it they'll take some of that and they'll
change some of the other ones and so we
need to have a language for explaining
each other's decisions humans need to
have a language for expressing what they
think - the machines we have coding for
that machine needs a language to express
to humans what they're doing and why on
the topic of coding and data I want to
talk a little bit about a bias in data
so one of the things that's often raised
with you know training algorithms
through providing with mass amounts of
data is that the data is inherently
human which means it could be inherently
biased or flawed and a lot of people
even call out you know potential you
know isms racism sexism those kinds of
biases that could work their way into
data but I actually want to talk more
just about capability what are the risks
of introducing the bias
of simply the fact that our data is
human in nature and that means that we
can only ever get something that we
produce that is human and never better
alright there's no doubt that human
bringing knowledge right and human bring
in biased by selecting the data in some
cases depending on what's the data set
that you've selected your machine is
gonna train from that data that that
bias can be very powerful right there's
a there's a principle in machine
learning which we call inductive bias
and this is essential to training and
that it's essentially if I can try to
simplify an inductive bias is
essentially the knowledge that we put in
to constrain the problem to make it
feasible to learn something so for
example when we do image classification
it's deciding what are the set of
classes the types of object right are we
going to look at five objects or five
million objects deciding what's the set
of objects that matter that we want to
be able to predict right this inductive
bias is very powerful because it allows
us to narrow in on learning the things
that we think are important the other
side of this is bias plain and simple
which is it's limiting the ability for
the machine to learn anything and so
that there's the good side and there's
the bad side of this and we have to be
very conscious when we design our system
we have current to be conscious to pick
a good inductive bias and also to check
our biases in terms of what data we use
there's a line of research people are
looking at very actively at building
models where we can actually a detect or
even revert bias in our predictions so
try to make decisions that don't exhibit
certain preferences for different types
and we're achieving some measure of
success for doing that I would say the
caveat is that we have to be aware of
our biases to do that so to be able to
balance away from a particular bias we
have to be on the watch for it and be
able to sort of name it to compensate
for it and so one of the ways we do it
is by over referees
sending underrepresented types of data
so rather than take the whole data as it
is uniformly we're gonna say well we
want to be better at this type of
behavior so we're gonna increase the
weight of that data reduce the weight of
that data and so there's sort of
algorithmic things we can do but then
they require us to put a little bit of
knowledge the completely unconscious
bias it's very hard to prevent okay and
is there any way we can break free of
not even bias but just limitation and
start talking I mean now we're kind of
getting into the realm of super
intelligence and things like that but
how do we actually go beyond it's not
just human bias but human capacity yeah
that's so that was the other part of
your question um in many ways this is
what reinforcement learning brings to
the table right supervised learning says
I will show you an example in a human
we'll put a label on it and then the
machine will learn these pairings in
reinforcement learning we have the
ability for the machine to learn from
itself to explore different strategies
and then to see these rewards there's
still the notion of a reward so when
they build the system to play go it
didn't have any games from experts but
someone still wrote down in that
computer program the fact that winning
the game was good and losing the game
was bad and if we had written it the
other way around we would have gotten a
beautiful go losing machines and so is
that he still has to be written in but
in reinforcement learning it's a you'll
write a lot less it doesn't mean that
it's not hard and one of the problems
were facing specifically with
reinforcement learning it's a problem
sometimes we call the value alignment
problem it's easy when you're building
an agent to play chess or to play go to
just say winning is good losing is bad
it's a lot harder when you build a robot
to drive in the street to figure out
what is the right reward function to
specify for our agent and there's that's
when we get into very difficult more
ethical issues of figuring out how to
trade off different choices and how to
write out the reward function the cost
function for these different choices
okay so following up on some of these
challenges there
a lot of sort of dystopic visions of
technological advancement there's a lot
of fear and anxiety especially in the
press around development perhaps our own
more agnostic perspective technological
development is neither always perilous
nor promissory so from your point of
view as an expert in AI what are the
sorts of things that sort of make you
perilous about this what our challenges
complications things that you see as
problems there's a there's a lot of
challenges ahead we've touched on a few
one of the challenge we perhaps den
touch on is issues of privacy and
security with respect to the data
there's a lot of data that is being
collected from people's behaviors that
data is stored shared in multiple
different ways thinking of how do we
preserve the integrity of the data
especially when we get into medical data
is very important to do and so we have
to figure out the right way to do that
there's something really subtle that
creeps in when you're doing machine
learning which is I mean everyone agrees
that you know the raw data should be
preserved and we should be careful about
who has access to it now you take this
raw data and you train a machine
learning algorithm that machine learning
algorithm captures something about the
data that's how it makes the decision
but people don't necessarily have any
qualms about sharing that algorithm and
distributing the algorithms and the
weights that are associated with that
contain a piece of that data and so
understanding carefully what it is that
we're sharing when we share data driven
system is a really interesting problem
that has both sort of technical aspects
as well as ethical aspect another
another one that that I spend some time
thinking about is how do we make sure
that we have a diverse representation in
terms of the people building the
technology building AI as a woman in
tech you know this
a familiar theme throughout my career
but there's really a sense that as
researchers a lot of our job is picking
the right questions to ask and when we
pick the question we're directing the
research agenda and so if we have a very
narrow segment of our population asking
all the questions and then building all
the technology then we're going to have
a pretty possibly narrow set of
technology and it's a challenge to get a
lot more contributions from a much more
diverse segment of our population do you
have do you have ways of maybe thinking
about how to bring in those diverse
perspectives or ways in which you engage
in it in your lab or a university
there's a lot of initiatives underway I
have to say the we had a beautiful
summer program at McGill last summer
called them AI for good which brought
together about 25 young women at the end
of their engineering or computer science
degree to do advanced training in AI as
well as practical projects and they had
industry mentorship or so on it's a
pretty small program it's 25 of them's
the kind of thing we would want to have
you know 5,000 people do but it takes a
lot of energy to push these initiatives
through but there's and this is just one
example there's these kinds of
initiative everywhere we're still I
think not super good about measuring the
impact of these things trying to figure
out how we can have the most impact as
we prepare to introduce coding into a
lot of the elementary school curriculum
thinking of a way to introduce coding
that is appropriate that it will appeal
to a large segment of the you know
children is really important and it's
not something that's necessarily easy
you've touched on this in several of
your answers but I feel like I might as
well ask explicitly what do you think
right now is the greatest bottleneck to
AI research ai development on the more
research side or on the more deployment
side by the way I think on the
deployment side by the thing we keep on
hearing is really the the bottleneck in
terms of talent the ability to train
more people in this relatively quickly
would say all the different sectors
right companies come to see me and they
want to hire my students much much
faster then I can help them develop and
so we have this challenge in terms of
training the next generation of students
how do you feel it's most appropriate to
train like do you feel like a five year
PhD graduate program is the ideal way to
train an IAI researcher they're quicker
ways or I don't know yet I think that
the the spectrum of opportunities is so
wide that there's an opportunity to do
better at all levels quite honestly
yeah I don't know what you guys think
you guys are like all early your latest
stage of a PhD they want to let us know
sooner that's I honestly think it's a
shame that students don't learn computer
science the way they learned chemistry
biology and physics which I think
probably there's things are probably
going to change I know nothing about
education but I feel like people are
thinking they're gonna try to put in
computer science programs into public
schools yeah I think we're ten years
late on that I wish we had started doing
that right ten years ago but better now
immediately than then in ten years okay
I think we're all done on time so just
on behalf of three of us and the entire
community at Massey thank you again so
much for the talk you know I think you
and I have the best jobs not only in
Canada but in the world you get to
interact with 150 fabulous junior
fellows like the three that we've just
heard from and I get the interact with
350 Seafire fellows of the kind like we
just heard from from Joe well Joe well I
want to thank you first for just an
amazing job of your enthusiasm your
ability to explain really complex
concepts and ideas and algorithms to a
very diverse audience it's just amazing
to watch it's a great performance I'm
not sure it's the same as a Glenn Gould
Rhonda Burke concerto piece but it's
pretty good so thank you very very much
for your time and for just doing a
wonderful job for all of us
Sasha Sasha Johanna and and chain you're
terrific
and every time I go to a sea far dinner
at Massey with junior fellows I leave
with the same feeling I have right now
which is the world's in good hands so
thank you very much for your time he
went when you and I had this
conversation three plus years ago of
having a partnership to bring CFR
fellows of the caliber of joe el pino to
talk about issues of the day that matter
at the nexus between science and society
I don't think we I certainly didn't
appreciate how important and how
relevant this would be and I think this
was like it was a great partnership and
I look forward to continuing this
partnership between seafaring Massey so
thank you very much I'd like to thank
all of you for coming I hope you found
the evening as stimulating and as a
format as of I have as I have you can
continue the conversation there'll be a
reception outside afterwards with either
of these any of these four individuals
and and your staff will be out there if
you want to ask the more questions about
CFR again I'd like to thank Hugh for
partnering with us on this great event
or we have an event coming up at on
November the 14th at it's our annual
dinner CFR's annual dinner at the Omni
King Edward hotel it is going to feature
a fabulous talk by another Seafire
fellow
Michele demo from Harvard University
she's co-director of C forest program in
successful societies Michele is Canadian
she's the president of the American
Sociological Association and she's this
year's recipient of the Erasmus Prize
which will be given by the king of the
Netherlands later this fall and Michele
will be talking about addressing the
recognition gap how to make societies
more inclusive thank you all again for
for your talk for your time and to the
audience for coming this evening and
please join all of us out in the
reception after this thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]